[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american science fiction
drama film called equals
spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie begins in a futuristic world
mankind went through a devastating war a
century earlier the war only left two
peninsulae suitable for inhabitants one
of the peninsulae works under a
legislative body called the collective
the collective has set extreme rules and
laws to make sure such a war does not
emerge again
the citizens of the peninsula are called
the members and the collective monitors
and controls all of the members actions
with a futuristic approach to solving
the problem everyone in the peninsula is
made mentally stable all emotions and
diseases have been eradicated people
live an automated life they do not talk
to each other unless they have to
the concept of friendship and
relationship is gone and any show of
emotion is considered illegal
marriage is non-existent in any form of
sexual activity is contrary to society's
rules
babies are born strictly through
artificial insemination
on the other hand no one knows what is
in the other peninsula people assume
that primitive human emotions are
allowed there
silas is a member of the peninsula he
too is mentally stabilized and is void
of any emotions
he works as an illustrator at atmos when
silas walks out of his futuristic home
we see that everyone around him is in
white attire
large skyscrapers spread throughout the
city and everyone seems to be automated
as per usual he walks into his workplace
a voice announces a disease called the
switch down syndrome more commonly
called sos it is a condition in the
members of the peninsula where their
mental stabilization stops working and
they start to get their emotions back
it has four stages and is considered
fatal by the collective the members are
daily reminded of the effects of sos via
an announcement
nia is sila's colleague and a fellow
member of the peninsula that day at
lunch the members eat in their outdoor
cafeteria while they engage in a
conversation about work nia stays
especially quiet while returning home
that night silas comes across two guards
restraining a man named david a woman
who is also restrained screams david's
name in dismay
the two are suffering from sos and have
gained their emotions back
they are being taken into a facility
called den defective emotional
neuropathy
dn was established by the collective to
hold in the patients suffering from sos
while not many people know of what
occurs inside the place it is rumored
that the people from the fourth stage
get killed mercilessly as the stages
beyond healing the display of emotions
unsettled silas
he then comes back to his apartment and
we get a full view of it it doesn't have
any decoration or furniture and is
highly modernized to pass his time silas
plays a futuristic puzzle game
the following day silas listens to the
news which reports that david and his
partner were arrested for being engaged
in sexual activities
as silas and his team work that day a
man jumps from the top of the building
to commit suicide the team watches the
dead body and talks about it coldly just
then silas notices signs of human
emotions in nia
her hands are tightened and she seems
nervous
he notices the oddness but doesn't think
much of it later they are in an
auditorium watching a presentation where
silas cannot stop looking at nia
at night he eats quickly and seems to be
enjoying his food
he doesn't play with puzzles either he
is beginning to go out of his automated
personality he dreams of his trying to
commit suicide and wakes up in distress
and hits his head this is the first time
he has ever had a nightmare
the following day he goes to the doctor
where he meets a man named jonas who is
in level 2 of sos the doctor checks
silas and it turns out that he has level
1 sos
he asks the doctor if he has to go to
the den but the doctor assures him that
cure at level one is easy and possible
at lunch silas again keeps staring at
nia
he seems to be observing her facial
features
silas gets his medication for sos and
takes it at night while listening to a
voice narrating the effects and causes
of sos
the voice adds that people with the last
stage of sos stage four are taken to den
and are electrocuted for showing
emotions
the sick will go through a pain-free
death scenario
the following day at work silas cannot
concentrate and is distressed he even
cries while working and tries to hide it
from his colleagues he follows nia
around work at all times the next
morning he switches his work with a
colleague to get closer to nia as she
explains the work to him he doesn't seem
to concentrate and keep staring at her
silas stays late after work and listens
to nia's recorded voice on her computer
he has begun falling in love with her
the next day silas and his team are in a
meeting when he accidentally drops a mug
of coffee he admits that he is suffering
from level 1 sos
the group collectively decides that
silas should stay as far as possible
while working so that the others feel
more comfortable
after work as nia leaves for her
apartment silas follows her
nia catches him in the act but silas in
turn questions her if she has sos too
he tells her about him noticing her
demure change when the guy committed
suicide that week
nia insists she is fine and leaves
the following day at work silas stays as
far as possible from everyone but
doesn't stop looking at nia the two act
like the conversation yesterday never
happened both of them work late that day
nia goes to the bathroom and silas
follows her he gets into her bathroom
stall and goes inside
the two are close when they touch each
other for the first time
silas feels nia's face in awe
nia reveals that she is at sos for a
year now she never went to the doctor
because she was afraid of being sent to
the
den she then tells him that their being
together is too risky so they can't meet
like this again
the two get up and finally kiss
it is now the next day and everyone has
left the office except the two
nia again leaves for the restroom and
silas follows the two hold on to each
other but are too afraid to move on with
a relationship they kiss again
from the following day they start
sneaking into the restroom every day
they laugh talk and kiss
the two are falling in love
one day admiss's manager leonard comes
into the restroom while the two are
together nia stays hidden while silas
goes out and talks to him
as it turns out someone had reported
silas's strange behavior to leonard he
warns silas of the consequences of
sneaking around and leaves
the two talk on their way back home and
silas tells her that he will look for
another job to not get caught so the
next day silas resigns from his job
a man named dominic replaces him as
silas gets a new job at a nursery
at night while picking up medicines
silas meets jonas again the two talk for
a while and jonas reveals that he is a
part of a support group with people who
are suffering from sos he offers to help
silas if he needs it
soon silas visits the support group and
meets its members namely bess peter
thomas gill max and alice
there he finds out that half the
patients brought to den commit suicide
as the staff encourages them
some even watch them kill themselves
as opposed to electoral restraints
suicide seems more preferable to
everyone
silas is shocked
later that night nia knocks on his door
he brings her inside and she breaks down
crying
she had missed him too much
one thing leads to another and the two
end up having sex
from the following day the two meet
every night at silas's apartment
silas has completely stopped taking his
medication
the two are beyond happy with their
lifestyle that is until one morning they
hear the announcement that a medication
to treat sos has been made
the announcer suggests everyone who has
been diagnosed with sos to take the
medicine
sos of any level can be treated with it
scared that they will not be able to
feel anymore silas and nia go to the
support group
they have decided to run away to the
other peninsula best tells them that it
is not a good idea but they have made
their decision
they decide to leave in three days with
jonas's help
however nia gets a conception call from
the collective they want her to
artificially bear a child
if the doctor checks her blood results
they will diagnose her with sos
scared she tells this to silas who asks
her to meet him at the clinic after her
appointment at the clinic the doctor
informs nia that she is pregnant silas
sees two guards taking her away but he
cannot do anything
they take her to dn
silas frantically asks jonas for help
who tells him to go home and wait for a
couple of hours
bess who is also a worker at dien frees
nia and takes her to the rest of the
support group they make her dress up as
fast as she can
best then explains to her that a patient
named eva had killed herself last night
bess has changed her records to nia's so
now nia can live freely as eva nia runs
away to silas's apartment but is
surprised when she doesn't find him
there
meanwhile silas is at work where it is
announced in the news that max had
reported bess jonas and gilead so now
all three of them were cured and void of
emotions he then runs to dn's
headquarters and asks a worker about mia
he informs him of her death
silas is devastated he goes blank and
starts having a panic attack
nia goes searching for him when he
doesn't return back to the apartment
meanwhile silas climbs on top of atmos's
building to commit suicide as he is
about to jump he changes his decision
when he gets back to his apartment he is
greeted by a worried nia she immediately
notices the mark on his neck
silas has been cured of sos
nia asks him why he did that to which he
replies that he thought she was dead the
cure only takes effect in six hours so
he only has one more hour before his
emotions go away
nia is still pregnant so she asks silas
to fight the cure the two still decide
to go through the plan to run away
the next morning silas remembers that he
loved her but doesn't feel it anymore he
tells her to get dressed to go to the
train as they had decided in the train
nia is disappointed as silas sits two
seats away from her nia reminisces of
all the good times with silas
just then he sits on the seat beside her
and holds her hand suggesting that he
will soon recover and gain his emotions
back
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching